welcome back to new rock stars we
finally have a trailer for the new
obi-wan kenobi series coming to disney
plus and boy oh boy does it look like a
banger
finally all my hard work and investing
in these prequel memes is about to pay
off big time if we don't get judge our
banks as a sith lord in this series we
riot and by we i mean me
my roommate jimmy and that guy who kind
of like i don't know if he lives in our
garage or if he just sleeps there but he
agrees with all my theories as long as i
give him a little bit of rum every night
in a dish like a little house cat
this is rogue theory the show where we
pitch the wildest theories for the nerdy
titles that we love my name is thomas
michael bechtold and i was born on a
small farm in upstate new york in 1980
something going rogue with me today is
the angel that all the deep space pilots
love to talk about it's my queen my muse
my everything jessica clements hello
jessica hi
that intro
i hate that i was first after that intro
it's so ridiculous i blacked out i
noticed absolutely
i absolutely have no recollection
ah also joining us today is someone
who's ready to tell you the tragedy of
doc plagueis the wise and host of the
philosophers podcast it's eddie
villanova hello eddie how are you hello
hello and i thought you were going to
tell them that i lived in your garage
what's going on just let him know our
relationship already tommy come on eddie
loves that rum oh you know
finally someone who really really hates
sand it's coarse it's irritating it's
off-screen producer brand oh boy do i
hate that sand it gets everywhere you
can't get it out of anything you got to
bring baby that's the worst thing that
happened to him right a baby yeah that's
exactly right
yeah use baby powder
stop there no it doesn't
no does too oh yeah
when i go to the beach i go head to toe
and baby powder
before you put on your latex suits tommy
i know i know i'm always going to look
like tom is going to look like that guy
from super troopers when they try to
de-louse him oh yeah
powdered sugar it's delicious
yes powdered sugar say shenanigans one
more time all right shenanigans the
first trailer for obi-wan kenobi the
series on disney plus finally dropped
yesterday my sister's birthday happy
birthday happy birthday happy birthday
it had star wars fans everywhere
duel belting the fates all day long
everyone's excited for who might show up
on this series but one character in
particular really has us wondering and
that leads us to our first topic darth
maul returned in the obi-wan kenobi
series the time frame in which the
series takes place means that everyone's
favorite dissected horny little devil
boy is still alive running the crimson
dawn even though maul doesn't know that
kenobi is hiding on tatarine could he
make a cameo in this series and if so
how might he appear i think one thing to
to kind of note i mean obviously we've
gotten great story lines with darth maul
in the clone wars as well as the uh
rebel series and to have that kind of
come to fruition and completion with the
rebel series it gave us so much content
it gave us so much information so
i feel like if there was a
ever a place in this series where we're
going to see darth maul it's going to be
on the part of him
trying to find the clues his own way
before he has to go to the sith temple
to get that power that he talks about in
rebels with ezra bridger
i feel like it's going to be more of
like him being more detective like
as opposed to deciding to go in that
direction which he doesn't want to go in
that direction because that means
leading him back to the sith and the
dark side of you know with uh palpatine
and all them so he's trying to stay
under the radar and maybe just be a
detective and try to find clues and you
know do the whole bad cop even worse cop
kind of thing i like that
i like that bad cop even worse cop going
back it's like when you go home and see
your old friends from high school and
they just drag you back into all your
old bad habits throwing snails down on
railroad tracks oh chicken potions
all that stuff you know all the stuff we
used to do is boys is that why i'm not
getting my amazon packages because
there's too many snails on the tracks
derailing me that's right snails on the
tracks break your mama's backs all right
okay i've got it i've got it i've got a
crazy rogue theory
do you want to go first jessica
you know yours is always crazy and
actually really good so let me go before
you so it's bad and then yours goes um i
love this setup
um i think i i mean
i kind of agree with eddie i kind of
agree with eddie i think what my
favorite part about darth maul is his
death and rebels and i think that's a
very big motivation for what the obi-wan
kenobi series would lead if we put darth
maul in there so i think what we're
gonna try seeing is eventually ob1 will
go underground not underground but like
like physically underground and somehow
fall into the arms of the crimson dawn
or something and obi-wan will darth maul
will be like
this is my enemy i need to make sure to
kill him like this is something happens
and so when we see darth maul in the
obi-wan kenobi series i think we're
gonna see him like str like just
constantly be
raged with like i need to fight obi-wan
kenobi so that way when we if people do
go see star wars rebels they'll be like
oh this is really serious like the death
scene is really sad and he's holding him
so i think
what we're gonna see is like more
obi-wan kenobi still being more
presentable and great about like just
being a jedi in the darth maul going
crazy and being like i need to kill him
but i don't think he's gonna appear so
much i think me and brandon kind of
talked about this it's gonna be more
about the inquisitors but when darth
maul does appear he's gonna be like
raged with anger and be like i don't
care what i'm doing i don't care if i'm
doing it right we gotta get obi-wan so i
think that's how it's gonna we're gonna
see darth maul's like somewhere
underground with the crumbs and dawn
sorry i almost sneezed that's that's no
no i thought you're just crying you're
so moved by it
exactly i love oh just got so worked up
about your own theory it was really sad
i remember being like that must be crazy
to spend your entire life trying to kill
this man and then you finally come to
peace with dying in his arms i love
villains i love a good villain story and
darth maul is a really good villain like
arc he's gone through absolutely we love
villains here i yeah i like you know
that i like your theory it does make
sense like obi-wan kenobi's whole life
is all about remaining in control and
remaining composed and his main
adversaries tend to be people who
go off of the of the path by losing
control and being too emotional i mean
really the most emotional we ever see
obi-wan is is on uh is on mustafar when
he's uh you know making
uh using a deli slicer on anakin to turn
him into a rotisserie choice
but i have to agree with like in in the
in the in the sense of what jess is
saying like the whole idea of who maul
is throughout that entire franchise
it just his entire journey is one that
oddly enough we are probably the closest
to in terms of from first appearance all
the way through
and that death scene
it's it's got so many big implications
and obviously everybody's seen the
explanation of you know obi-wan and how
he holds his lightsaber and and this
isn't that but it's like it's true you
find that dynamic between those two is
like complete like magnetic polar
opposites where every time they come
together it's just immense blows it
happened all throughout the entire clone
wars series and having that great ending
in the most simplistic way of it of how
it goes
any kind of retconning that would really
just mess up a lot of fans they have
well i'm gonna retcon
who's here to mess up the fans well like
here's here's what i love with like what
dave fulon is doing with star wars right
he's just taking time and cutting it up
into smaller and smaller pieces and
being like here's a show about this four
hours in the star wars universe and blah
blah blah so i think this is gonna be a
weird moment for maul right he's uh he's
running the crimson dawn now he's he's
he's throwing away the whole sith thing
right he's just maul baby screw the sith
i got cut in half i was a patsy i got
set up it's [ __ ] right he's pissed
off and he's afraid so so now you have
like the empire growing they're growing
ranks they got these inquisitors running
around who's not doing good for business
for anybody and even though the empire
they do wind up working with like the
huts and stuff and using like
underground they do cut out a lot of the
like crime right because they're trying
to clean up the universe in the way they
see it how it should be run so i think
that darth maul is actually or maul's
gonna be up against the inquisitors and
up against the empire who are trying to
crush the crimson dawn at this point and
he's gonna be pissed and the enemy of my
enemy is my friend and i think we're
gonna get a little twister rooney here
and obi-wan and maul are gonna have to
team up reluctantly to go up against
these inquisitors because they're not
good for business for anybody and i
think you know obi-wan's main antagonist
here is gonna be anakin right it's gonna
be darth vader showing up again being
like you could have realized like this
out of my match and he's like he's gonna
be the pissed off rage one and i think
maul maul and obi-wan are gonna work
together as like buddies and then go
their separate ways at the end of this
series and that'll set up you know the
the the moving death we get in rebels
right where it's like they had this
moment where they were where their
interests were aligned and they worked
together because i think you know maul's
at this point where he's like screw the
sith and i think
obi wan once a little bit like screw the
jedi i've seen how this has gone bad
i've seen how this has gone bad so
i think they're going to work together
in this
they can still work together and then
still butt heads at the end oh yeah
y'all could just be like psych bam and
hit him upside the head at the very end
of it he could like at the very end
you know maul pulls out the chair from
behind and just hits obi-wan in the back
baby obi-wan has gone out of i think a
couple times every time maul does get
obi-wan someone saves obi-wan so we can
have another scene of obi-wan just
getting saved again that way we don't
get rid of that like intense storyline
and the clone wars and the rebels uh so
i think making their i agree with
brandon too give brandon my my [ __ ]
one is better so we're shipping them
we're calling them obi-wan
uh we're gonna do the points a little
different today we're gonna be handing
out tommy tokens those are redeemable at
my uh at my website www.tomsquad.com
in my best merchandise section which is
why i have exclusive new rockstars
merchandise slandering the other talent
on this show for instance you can buy a
mug that says eric voss more like eric
loss philip molina hope i never see you
whitney van landingham more like whitney
pass on over that uh because i ain't
landed anywhere near her ass
all right so head on on down to that
fictional
website that does not exist but let's
hand out our tommy tokens uh eddie i'm
gonna give you two tommy tokens for uh
you know i'm not gonna lie a safe theory
but still a spicy theory jessica you
were gonna get two tommy tokens but then
you gave them to brandon because they oh
when you get obi-wan kenobi and darth
maul together in a theory you're gonna
get the token so i'm gonna give brandon
three tokens three tommy tokens which is
about halfway to an eric voss more like
eric lost mug so you're halfway there
guys up next we're gonna talk about the
new batman series coming to hbo max but
first a few words from our sponsors
newrockstarsmerch.com has four different
shirt designs inspired by the batman
they also have hoodies socks stickers
and more stuff that's the perfect gift
for the moody millionaire in your life
or just for your buddy who can't stop
saying by vengeance
ever since he saw the movie check out
all of our great options at
newrockstarsmerch.com and tell them
tommy sent you don't do that that'll do
nothing that there's no if you do that
the site will just crash all right let's
talk about some of our sponsors today
some best friends of mine first thing i
want to talk about is ferrity spring
weather can be a little like the planets
of the star wars universe one day it's
as cold as hoth the next it's muggy like
dagobah our buddy's over at faraday make
picking the right spring outfit easier
because they make perfect clothes for
all seasons winter spring summer fall
rosemary dill chipotle all the seasons
verity is a family-run brand making high
quality timeless clothing that looks
great and is super functional look at me
i'm not wearing it and i could barely
move if i had ferry i'd be moving around
they make the clothes that always work
their way to the top of your rotation
around new rock size we're all big fans
of faraday clothes they make us feel
like we're fashionable at hip which are
two words people don't usually throw
around for folks that speculate about
star wars verdi is so confident in the
quality of their stuff they have a
lifetime guarantee of quality so if
you're one of those immortals like darth
plagueis the wise someone who found a
way to cheat death you're going to be
wearing faraday clothes for millennia
they'll replace or fix their clothes
forever no matter what talk about making
it easier to get dressed imagine you're
90 and you get too close to a fence
chasing a rabbit or something confuses
you you tear a hole in your farady shirt
they'll replace it for you talk about
making it easier to get dressed and
right now faraday has given the rogue
theory audience 20
off that's one fifth for those of you
math nerds head down to faradybrand.com
and use code rogue at checkout to snag
twenty percent off all your new spring
staples that's code rogue at faraday
f-a-h-e-r-t-y
brandt.com for 20
off and tell them tom sent you all right
up next
my favorite sponsor sponsor that's
gotten me through a lot of long nights
i'm talking about bluetooth baby we're
not always confident in our theories
here on rogue theory but if you need
confidence in life and in the bedroom
that's where blue chew comes in luchu is
a unique online service that delivers
the same active ingredients as viagra
and cialis but in a chewable tablet at
the fraction of the cost you can plan
ahead or be ready whenever an
opportunity arises and if you've always
thought i need to get into but i want to
eat it like pez blue chew has solved
this problem for you i know you pez
heads out there with your grinch pez
machine and you're like why can't i get
hard it's so hard to swallow a pill let
me chew it down the process is simple
sign up at bluetooth.com sell with one
of their licensed medical providers and
once you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days and then you're
off to the chew races my friends it's
all done online no visits to the
doctor's office no awkward conversations
no looking down at your pants to make
sure the pleat doesn't make it seem like
you already took a blue chew you'll
receive your prescription there's no
waiting in line at the pharmacy
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
baby red white and blue too and prepared
and shipped direct to your door in a
discrete package but you know what i say
i don't want the discreet package i want
it in big letters boner town destination
tom bechtold's townhouse okay if you
could benefit from the extra confidence
when it's time to perform let blue chew
help you we've got a special deal for
our audience try bluetooth free when you
use the promo code rogue at checkout
just pay five dollars shipping that's
five dollars for a god torpedo in your
gym shorts that's bluetooth.com promo
code rogue to receive your first month
free visit bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
and we thank buchu for sponsoring this
show for saving my marriage when i've
got my stamp socks on i know my feet are
both comfortable and stylish and that
matters to me now they're taking that
comfort and style from toe to head with
the launch of their all-new active
apparel life stance has a super soft
line of sweatpants and joggers shirts
hoodies and more they look as good as
they feel they're available in a full
range of fits prints of fabrics not a
yellow guy don't worry about it full
range that means green blue indigo
violet reds even possibly whites and
grays i think the coolest part of
stanton's apparel is all their
collaborations with artists and
different ips where their nightmare
before christmas hoodie over their bob
marley t-shirt with incredible hulk
socks and let the world know all the
stuff you're into at the same time
stance's philosophy is that you should
never have to sacrifice your own style
for the sake of comfort and now you
don't have to whether you're relaxing
around the house working out at the gym
or running all over town like me
bonafide businessman tom beck told
stance now delivers its signature
softness and creativity in a full line
of active apparel styles from toe to
head talking to toenails baby stance has
got you covered head on over to
stance.com and get 15 off your first
purchase use promo code rogue at
checkout to apply enjoy the color and
comfort of a life less ordinary with
stance stitch different and we're back
hbo max has officially confirmed this
week that a new series focusing on colin
farrell as the penguin is headed into
production and that leads us to our
second topic for today friends what can
we expect from the penguin on hbo max
with the batman now in theaters matt
reeves looks to expand his version of
gotham with an all-new series on hbo max
focusing on the penguin everybody's
favorite
edm nightclub odin
irish guy in a fat suit so tell me now
when the penguin where could this series
take us to set us up for the events for
a sequel to the batman i can go first
but also i just want to acknowledge that
nightclub didn't look fun also there's
so many there are so many batman movies
where batman is just beating up people
in a nightclub and i'm just like why is
it always a nightclub because nightclub
people are dangerous can't trust that i
guess it looked like a place where you'd
stub your toe a lot or bump into like
metal like how do you think they figured
out how to do all their dancing they're
they've just all been stubbing
themselves into things
it feels like it's easy to fall over the
pole there's always like there was just
like a metal pole and it was like oh if
i fall off it's like 50 feet
like that nobody's gonna find you until
they hit the lights it's so hard to get
i was like that the twin brothers from
the leftovers got got in that movie that
was awesome that was my they were my
favorite people in that whole movie oh
i'm glad you're like they were on
desperate housewives
at least that's what my wife said i
didn't know for sure but they she said
they were desperate that's what my wife
said
right
the gals of wisteria lane yeah i watched
oh my god okay i watch i think that
there's a lot of room for what the next
the sequel of the batman will be because
the penguin has no story right now from
the movie so i think a great way of
going about this is introducing ethan
cobblepot the penguin's son whose mother
was one of the workers at the iceberg
lounge and when
i think the story was like that she was
like hey i'm pregnant with your child he
was like hit the road lady and then he
goes on to like pay for the child all
throughout his like life and so he goes
to college and then he's like i'm paying
for your [ __ ] anymore and he becomes a
villain eventually and then his enemy is
bat girl i think i think it's bad girl
and so i think a really i think that
would just tie in really well just the
family of who penguin is the fact that
he has a son we could even take from the
harley quinn series where he has a
nephew and a sister and his mother who
are very big important characters and
how that sways how he's doing in life
and then in the sequel the batman we can
have ethan cobblepot show up and though
he is kind of like a shitty villain he
still is a money-making villain so if
the penguin did die ethan cobblepot
could take his role um as his new dad
so that is what i have to say that's
what i think it's going to be
interesting yeah i i kind of been with
you on the the development we have a lot
to learn about uh the penguin i thought
it was interesting all the criticism
that that that movie took for that
character as if like there wasn't enough
information already given in that movie
about so many characters they were like
how could they not develop the penguin
fully it's like well because they're
doing a tv show in sequels to this movie
this wasn't supposed to be the complete
story of oswald cobblepot so
and chester copperpot from the goonies
which i would also like to have him in
are they are they gonna establish the
link between those two characters the
grandfather time to bring the goonie
verse and the in the dc
my pirate ship is stuck in a cave
i have the key to one-eyed willie
oh man um i i would say i i like that
direction but i would say with the way
we've seen with uh the success of
peacemaker i feel like his son will be a
part of it but i feel like his son is
going to be like a
gen zier somebody who's more in tune
with like pop culture and things of
what's going on and he's going to kind
of
the entire series is going to be the
penguin trying to understand his son's
culture and just not getting it and
getting him more frustrated and each
episode it's another aspect of like no
dad don't you get this is you know
facebook you do this and then
whatever uh then turned into arnold a
little bit um and then you're gonna get
like opportunities where each time it
just gets him more and more frustrated
until we see him be like the insane just
masochist type of villain at the end of
it and have him just go off and be like
i'm gonna go kill the band man or
something no so are you suggesting that
this will be like a comedy yeah it's
like this interactions will be funny
yeah so so this will have more like a
peacemaker tone where there's action but
also a lot of humor yeah oh i like that
eddie i like that i'm trying to remember
what matt reeves movies he's done that
are
comedy to see what it's going to be like
and i immediately was like i guess
planet of the apes was kind of funny
had some jokes in it yeah it's so funny
a lot of people don't know he directed
earnest scared stupid that's not true
when
[Laughter]
that is true i i think he's gonna go
more violent than anything i think he's
gonna take that especially like a crime
boss like he's gonna be like oh i can't
wait to see penguin stab people in the
neck because if there's one thing i
learned about peacemaker is that there's
a lot of butts a lot of dicks and a lot
of blood so he's probably gonna take
from that and do a bunch of that [ __ ] do
you think it's gonna go in the direction
of like boardwalk empire oh my god i
would lose my mind if they did the
boardwalk empire so i would lose my [ __ ]
boardwalk empire was one of the greatest
television shows and i was so sad that
when it went and so if they follow that
suit and make it as vicious as like the
wire
i'll be like oh i'm into this i love
this well one thing i was reading was
that this penguin series was originally
like the the story was gonna be the
sequel for the batman and they decided
like no we'll just pivot this into a
series but i do think you're kind of
right uh jessica and eddie like i think
this is gonna get a little it's gonna be
about the rise of penguin you know
they've kind of taken out
two major crime families in the batman
universe and modern batman has very much
shied away from these villains and been
like no the real crime bosses are like
the maroneys and the falcones and
they're they're like you know the
sopranos or whatever and like copperbots
like like right he's like a joke a lot
and even in this movie he was kind of
toothless right it was like i didn't
kill any goyals what are you doing
you're the worst you're the worst
detectives ever waddling around and
stuff and i think he now now cabo pot
has seen like oh this city you know i
can take over now but i'm gonna have to
up it up a notch you know i'm gonna have
to be willing to kill some people and do
some some really evil stuff but i like
the idea of like his family being there
and him kind of moving away from his
family and like you know now that the
flood has come he's gonna take over some
sections of the city and really build
himself up and now that they've said
that like the the other show they're
gonna do isn't gonna focus on the gotham
pd anymore but it's going to focus more
on arkham i'm wondering if they'll use
the penguin show to kind of bridge
the gap into some of the more fantastic
villains because watching the batman i
was like how does superman exist in this
world right this world that seems very
practical and dark and like not a lot of
magic in it how do you have a character
like superman or any any villain who's
who's a meta human or like has mystical
powers or something i don't see that
existing in the batman that we saw but
this could help us do it in like
cobblepot show where like in the penguin
maybe he meets some more fantastic
villains and that's a good way to
introduce them into
the batman that matt reeves has created
i actually what i'm hearing is bring on
mr mixel please
i actually i i did the reading on uh the
book that came out before the movie it's
like before the batman or whatever um
and it it really does kind of set up
penguin as this like super low-key but
starting to make plans to take over kind
of thing like the whole book surrounds
this situation where uh penguin is
having one of his henchmen
uh sell this super top secret type of
explosive
and he's forcing this person to sell it
because he's framing her dad
and he's in jail so but in the end like
the henchman is the one who gets it in
the end and falcone is like he thinks
that penguin's up to things but he's
kind of suspect and he's like you know
but the book really does set up a
premise where the penguin already is
making moves
um
in the book this is the one that batman
finds but it's already kind of
insinuating that the penguin has already
making moves and doing things
uh prior to that's been trying to
underhand what karma carmine falcone's
been doing
and uh
to really kind of set himself up as a
top villain
so there's precedence to it i just
thought of something two things a i
don't know if my theory would actually
work because it's following the exact
storyline of falcone and selena and uh
in the new batman so i'm like why would
he do the exact same thing unless it is
mirroring the same situation of like how
batman was like your dad thought he was
doing good and then did bad like if they
wanted to do that double up again and
it's like you wanted to be better than
falcone but you are actually being
falcone also i do think the series will
probably play more until like because he
immediately was like looks like i'm the
new leader [ __ ] and then it's like well
what about the people that also want to
be the leader what about other people
that worked for falcone that are like no
i'm the leader and there's no better
like story than like a bunch of high-end
villains fighting each other endlessly
so i think it's gonna be a lot of him
trying to take control of what he thinks
is his but he has to fight everyone for
it um i would love his family to come in
though yeah and we haven't really gotten
a chance to see all the other crime
families and every uh and every
opportunity that we've seen you know
batman explore the entire crime family
syndicates uh like with bat the dark
knight uh we saw all those people at the
table those all are representative of
you know the different crime families in
uh
under the red hood we saw you know the
meetings of all the crime families we've
seen that there are more than just the
falcons and the maroneys but it's it
hasn't been kind of come to fruition so
maybe that could be part of the series
as well the penguin coming in and just
one after one like just taking over each
crime family knocking off the heads of
that family and just making his
penguin army massive with uh with
henchmen yes if there's anything we like
the batman is that you need those
henchmen because the riddler had his
goblin team the godfather and the
riddler yeah the regular head is in
cells
social media army no it's like you need
your own he's got 500 followers
was that the only one when i saw the
little kid at the very beginning right
and he's dressed as a red ninja
and he like fake kills his dad
everyone's like oh he's gonna become
robin i was thinking he's gonna become
red hood like what if they they kind of
subvert it all and he sees all this go
down he sees what happened to his dad
and he's like no i'm gonna run this town
now you don't kill me
he definitely don't kill don mitchell
politician children other than batman
arguably um turn evil so in in these in
these franchises none of them ever
turned good um i say arguably some of
them just developed cocaine addicts and
marry fox news anchors that's also true
did anybody else get a vibe of uh maybe
a league of shadows type reference there
yeah there's an opportunity there too uh
i like it guys i like the angles we're
going here i'm gonna award some tommy
tokens now these are redeemable at my
website www.tomsquad.com
where you can buy newly minted nfts
that's nice face tommy these are unique
images of me making a cutie boy face
into the camera so
uh jess i'm gonna give you tommy tokens
uh two of them eddie i'm gonna give you
another two tommy tokens and uh brandon
i'm gonna give you one tommy token
because you kind of just agreed with
jessica
and i want to make it more
i want to make the rogue question more
dramatic and if i gave you two it would
be out of reach so now's the time that
we all watch for the rogue question and
if you've made it this long obviously
you're watching on the toilet and having
some gastrointestinal issues and we wish
you well
so today's road question is as we wait
to hear any news on captain america four
apparently anthony mackie and sebastian
stan haven't spoken in months maybe it's
something about anthony mackey leaking a
racy tape between pam and tommy and
recently sebastian stan said he hopes
that anthony doesn't have any say if
he'll be in captain america four this is
probably all one big joke amongst
friends using the internet as its play
thing for today's rogue question i just
want us to play a little like you know
fantasy and we were on set fly on the
wall what's the pettiest real world beef
that these two actors could have oh what
made them dislike each other what's the
pettiest beef oh my god you know i think
they broke the number one rule for any
actor whether it's in in theater on the
stage on the silver screen wherever it
is you don't touch
anyone else's props you know what i mean
you don't touch any prop that's not
yours and i bet i bet you know anthony
mackinney came around the corner or
something and sebastian was in that
you know that winged captain america
suit oh like throwing some punches
taking some selfies
you don't touch my props
don't touch a wig if it's not your way
yeah i i think i think it's a little bit
more egregious than that i feel like
not just you know with
with the code for people who act
together but the code for people who are
bros together
i feel like
sebastian stan or one of them
accidentally wore the other one's
underwear
because everybody accidentally bros
share clothes we share you know and it's
cool but one thing you don't share is
you don't share underwear that's the
number one rule and i feel like one of
them was like these look like mine
grabbed them put them on because i mean
they travel they're in you know they
they're all on set elsewhere whatever
things can happen or whatever and one's
like oh yeah there's mine and then one's
hey
are you wearing my fruity looms i
thought these were mine and boom civil
war three fruit of the crazy thing is
they're both wearing batman underwear oh
yeah absolutely
cross-branded oh yeah you can't do that
all right jessica what do you think i
think
i think that
this is stupid i think that i think that
um anthony and mackie
and
sebastian stan have always had this beef
and they've been laying it low because
they've been just like you know we have
to do all these movies together but i
feel like anthony mackie auditioned for
jeff galloway and i tonya and sebastian
stan guys
i think anthony mackie yeah
i think he auditioned for the role of
tommy lee and pam and tommy but
sebastian stan got it
he auditioned for the special agent in
355 but sebastian stan got it
he's just like look here i'm gonna get
my own and he gets black mirror and it's
the worst episode
and so they've always had this beef
because sebastian stan's been stealing
as the amaki's roles and so anthony
mackie's been laying low but also
spitting out a lot of rumors to people
on set being like you know who's a piece
of [ __ ] sebastian stan and sebastian sam
was like you know what i really hope
he's not in this movie because i just
can't stand him right now we need to
break apart from each other because he's
mad that i keep stealing his roles that
are clearly for me uh and before anybody
watches this and says jessica what's
your problem with anthony mackie i don't
have a problem with anthony mackie i
just think him and smash the stand
audition for the same roles and clearly
smash that is getting it so
sebastian stan can't get it when is
hollywood gonna have the guts to let a
black man play tommy lee come on come on
let anthony mackie play jeff galloway
we are asking the real questions here we
were asking the real question
you know that one got way more real than
i thought it was gonna but at the end of
the day i have to award the token to a
man i've done sketch comedy with it
knows the sacred rule you don't touch my
wig and you don't touch my cape you
don't touch my wig you don't touch my
cape therefore brandon you're getting
the tommy tokens and that makes you
today's winner oh baby
i'm going to tomsquad.com immediately
i need you to open a digital wallet uh
what we call a little tommy a little
tommy trunk that's what they're going to
steal from you tommy
we got we got people on the blockchain
we got people off the chain okay that's
it for this episode of rogue theory
thanks to our special guests jessica
clements eddie villanueva an off-screen
producer
branded support our channel by checking
out all of our awesome merch over at
newrockstarsmerch.com
if you have thoughts on some of our
rogue theories you can share them on our
discord if you're over 18 click on the
link for the new rockstars discord
server in the description below follow
me at tommy bechtold follow new
rockstars on all social platforms and be
sure to subscribe to our channel on
youtube and we'll see you next time
goodbye
[Music]
you